idée capable de battre garry kasparov
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
waouh
et bien c
ici chronique
pour
chronique réfléchi
en italie se ronge les ongles quand même
hein il est énervé sa préparation n'a
pas suffi kasparov le la démonter
tranquille ramener qui est en train de
le rattraper au temps là il est passé
sous la barre d une heure ça fait 28 qui
réfléchit ap adam prend b2 pas de
solution il n'y a pas de solution ici
boukrami cherche mais qu'est ce qu'il va
trouver
ce qui peut pas jouer tour c'est cette
chronique tour c'est cette wii alors qu
intéressant on va le proposer mais enfin
c'est pas très intéressante ça mais
quand même ça pourrait l'être
l'idée c'est que si tôt prendre tour
évidemment il ya d'un point 9-8 donc ça
laisse les tour en action sa menace d'un
projet sept matches ça laisse des pièces
sur l'échiquier médias carrier des
scènes peut-être kg vite bientôt prendre
tour où il a fait ça il a joué et on
prend tout mouais allait s'élever et ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle stéphane ah bon
bah oui parce qu'il va pas proposer
mieux là après je lève non mais non mais
oui mais kaspar comme ça ça veut dire
qu'il a décidé de la jouer à la meinau
et amis de lycée est allé pisser d'aller
pisser grandit alors pour ça nous avons
alors un moyen de vérifier ses fans
puisque toutes les allées et venues des
champions vers les toilettes sont notés
oui donc bon mais là je pense sont
consignés à l'énoncé possible alors je
vais prendre un petit carnet on est pour
noter que kramnik donc toilettes
ouais c'est important alors n'ont
peut-être pas là puisque les importantes
mais justement mais j'espère faut signer
en fait un oui des sports s'en va
travnik est parti et kasparov aussi
alors
elle est non mais là c'est l'espagne
elle se juche chronique
va-t-il jouer cette partie va-t-il
trouver quelque chose on peut se
demander l entrée plus personne n'est là
la position sur l'échiquier c'est celle
ci l'a évidemment on avait envisagé
qu'il ya des six ans vous voyez pas où
les blancs voulait en venir aux gens qui
avaient 6 c'est vrai qu'est-ce qui a
d'autres comme vous et bien on ne sait
pas trop [ __ ] russe vladimir kramnik
300 mwh devrait jouer assez vite je
pense à kelly des six
la question fait revenu kasparov attend
une proposition de nul c'est
vraisemblable quand les deux joueurs les
deux joueurs étaient partis des deux
joueurs sont revenus à mon avis gary ici
il attend que le crâne n'est que propose
nul il veut vérifier quand même garry
kasparov
chronique le mur surnommé le mur par les
journalistes anglais
on va tout à fait de wall kramnik du
wall peut-on passer kramnik
et quand il joue là dernier noise on
l'appelle le mur de berlin oui
effectivement
personne ne passe la divers comme dit à
part michael adams le flegmatique
anglais oui michael adams me renseigne
mondiale actuelle s'il ya quand même
battu tram dit que alors qu'il était 6e
voilà est ce qu'il a vu quelque chose
comme non non non mais là on n'est pas
sans qu'ils aient des 6 et espoirs veut
mettre sa tour hautement probable d'un
problème toi 1,8
c'est quand même c'est quand même
curieux de jouer ce coup pour à 8,1 et
celle au sol ouais c'est le seul puisque
surtout rita dahle trois salles à tour
revient sur la case avis tout allait pas
du tout active enfin rappelé qu on va
remontrer la position un passeport ne
peut pas enlever la tour de la 8e
puisque s'y cassent pas on joue on va
montrer loi dans ces six comparer ces
deux tours ces deux actifs qu à leur
actif et bien et noir jour est damée
fuite et chez cora il faut jouer cali g8
qui a pas d'autres coûts et là là deux
possibilités pour mater conventionnelle
2 puisqu'elles sont thématiques dont la
plus simple évidemment celles qui aiment
cette qualif cet échec et mat dit le
matin à l'étouffée puisque le roi noir
ne peut pas bouger parce qu'il est pris
par ses propres pièces étouffé par ses
propres pièces voilà sortir autre
possibilité également thématique c'est
sur le thème du mode du couloir
ah oui on peut prendre roi prend il à
tour vite matt torre huit matches
puisque le roi une fois de plus ne peut
pas sortir sur ces deux cases puisqu'il
a ses pions et le cavalier des six
contrôles la casa cette crise a fait
donc trois cases où le roi pourra les
wind up made des couloirs ce qui
s'appelle le mag du couloir
voilà voilà donc là que la toro doit
venir sur les cases habitent c'est
obligatoire
et oui tours à huit a l'air obligatoire
puisque les autres cases ainsi la tour
via un g8 tiamat du coup devient mater
tous fait aussi peut-être fait direct si
la tour va sur les cases devant la dame
et elle est en prise oui et lembeye 8 se
serait pas bon parce qu'on prendra le
pion à 7 avec un gain de temps tout à
fait je sais évidemment c'est l'atout
vient si bien fred hamon prend à 7
on gagne un temps puisque on attaque la
pointe des traitements lorsque leur joue
ensuite on reviendra probablement un set
blanc et non à gagner un million pour
rien voilà oui donc qu'à ce poste doit
jouer pour habiter réfléchir on sait pas
pourquoi que autour des 8 ça peut avoir
une idée des lois parce que si a promis
la torah 1,8 en attaque le pion à deux
mois et enfin tourner vite séchées en
quinze années après h 6 6 les bleues
ainsi d'attaquer on fait tout reprendre
à deux et c6 et se termine non je ne
porte pas de tassement fait en 08/09
sont comme ça et pas clair si t'es sport
je tombais vite et bien non mais tomber
vite c'est pas loin mais mais mais on se
sera une surprise
ouais mais pourquoi pas surprise
gigantesque temps les huit mais ça il
peut y avoir une idée tour v8 intérêt à
ce que la torre muant des huit cas
invite ces mêmes questions pour tous les
enfants peuvent faire autre chose sans
prendre le pion ouais voilà donc la faut
se demander si la tour émis en 2008 ce
qui semble le je suis pas là une caisse
de liberté de plus il peut les enlever
cette alors qu'en invite l peux pas m'en
faire mouche pas
là
kasparov en réflexion alors que le coup
semble forcée il reste 36 minutes
kasparov 36 35 35 minutes pour jouer dix
neuf coups ça fait donc moins d'une
minute par courriel loi diminue par coup
une île parcouru minutes 30 pour apple
min 38 min 30
une minute 30 parcours de moyenne donc
la moitié du temps initial temps moyen
initial le temps moyen initial étant de
3 milieu de parcours
kasparov maintenant on a plus qu'une
minute 30 parcours pour atteindre le 40e
coup puisqu'il ne reste que 35 minutes
et chroniques lui il reste 56 minutes
quand même curieux que
bof bof bof
on ne sait pas à quoi ils garantissent
pas fléchi stefano c'est quand même
vraiment hausse et c'est bizarre ouais
j'ai un jeu bizarre c'est bien ça sent
le grand se sent le coup monté
nous coup monté je ne vois pas ce que tu
veux dire est ce qui aurait pas mon
enseigne à bat yam à deux partout sauf
si tu y parviens à vite monde élite ou
alors il peut peut-être un guide
envisage que tu as donné à tourner
salaires aberrant stéphane hains de
jouer aux dames ces deux dames c'est
trop oui mais il n'y a pas d'idée il va
prendre 7 points 2 ou encore ou alors
n'hésitez pas autre possibilité derniers
seront pas abandonnés non mais c'est
possible
imaginons hiyama de force et on ne l'a
pas vu non mais la vue l'ordinateur
l'aurait vu non non non pas du tout
c'est peut-être un match à très très
long terme
si ça se trouve coup de théâtre
incroyable garry kasparov abandonne main
c'est donc ça serait super mais c'est
comme quand il a abandonné contredit
blue et alors que s'étaient alors que
c'était nul mérité tu te fais tout le
monde se rappelle des finales évidemment
on va re situer le match
kasparov contredit par blue new york 97
ha ha non il a joué son v8 et oui bon
voilà l'idée et oui tu vois tout à fait
incroyable n'a jamais dit il est
vraiment phénoménal ce stéphane laborde
il trouve les coups de casque même quand
ceux ci on est complètement idiot oui
parce que tomber vite si on prend à 7
on joue la tour après la dame on revient
et on va 1,8 en attaque à deux est prêt
on jouera six pour se prémunir des maths
et ensuite tu reprends à 2 qui crée une
contre attaque décisive forçant les
blancs à prendre là nul et c'est terminé
enfin stéphane quand même j'ai beaucoup
de mal à comprendre la pointe de ce
contour des mais le problème c'est qu'on
n'est pas obligé pour les blancs ne
prendre qu'un set s'il ya une attaque on
peut la continuer tout de suite c'est
clair
ici l'homme n'étant donc propose
évidemment de 1.7 et revenir en recettes
après ce qui aurait ouvert les colonna
mais il propose également calvi f7 qu'on
va regarder plus en détail cette fois ci
plus calmement on va y aller très cool
après roger vite qui est le seul coup
d'oeil
plusieurs possibilités pour vladimir
kramnik calais des huit vraisemblement
stéphane dans un premier temps il faut
bouger ce cas il faut le replacer
ailleurs possibilité c'est qu'elle est
de 8,7 en est une qui menacent maths et
de 8,6 à l'air force à nos stats sa
menace de 8,1 en montre montrant le et
loire invite dans huit échecs et
qu'après cavaliers prend à aimer tout
reprend échec et mat puisque le roi ne
peut pas sortir à cause du cavaly des
huit qui protège la casaque cette
variation soi-même tel donc ici il faut
se prémunir contre ça il faut jouer le
coup éventuellement h61 c'est pas
éventuellement c'est même sûr c'est même
sûr et là il faut regarder stéphane le
groupe avait dit aussi ce repas soit le
stockage nas en maths et apprendre à
équilibrer la tour e 1 peut-être nous
lance stéphane je ne comprends pas tout
cette position là on sera obligé de
jouer cavalier 5 avec les noirs km/h un
salaire pas comme c'est probable
avec la dame b2 qui va pouvoir revenir
en défense tout à fait hélas alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut envisager dans
cette position je ne sais pas ouais ça a
pas l'air c'est àdire foudroyant non ça
va pas d'air de donné grand chose
natation c'est clair que ça suffit pas
un peut-être si on peut jouer avec la
très loin avec l'idée de tours 5
le comité insiste protégeant mais la
dame noire pourrait faire mal à sénéchas
capitule sur cases blanches peut-être
non oui c'est ce à quoi les voiles est
envisageable
ouais ça ça c'est embêtant je ne sais
pas non on ne trouve pas il faut bien le
dire nous allons ainsi c'est très très
difficile à calculer
non mais ce qu'on ne comprend plus on
rapporte que ce qui se passe
kasparov qui je tourne des huit grammy
qui a l'air de réfléchir on ne sait pas
il ya des perspectives
oui non peut-être grandi gagnant non
cramique fait une chronique regarde le
public non mécanique peut pas perdre ça
c'est sûr il annule quand il veut il
suffit de jouer de pourchasser la tour
tout simplement vous dames c'est cette
voie la tour doit obliger de revenir en
fuite ou moins 1 point à 8 puis en
attaque encore la tour on peut attaquer
la torre de façon perpétuelle ouais
ouais
le mouvement perpétuel existe voilà est
rien on ne peut pas empêcher ça on
kramnik fait nul quand il veut première
chose
la deuxième chose grave ni katy diop la
nulle ça me paraît douteux et c'est là
qu'on ne sait plus trop
le problème c'est que dès que les blancs
ici d'amener la torah l'attaquent
baignade amorphe et des échecs
oui partout bon on peut envisager d'un
bébé un orage et 2006 c'est fini ça sent
le tour peut pas vraiment aller à la
taxe était fan je vois pas comment elle
passerait à l'attack là pour l'instant
non mais moi je réfléchisse adams et 7,3
fuite tours 7
mais il n'a directement des chèques
perpétue valait 1 échec perpétuelle donc
qu'est-ce qui va faire elle son cavalier
non mais là c'est nul
ouais et ce n'est pas grave quand
c'était foutu fait naître un peu
déconfite est ce que tu peux nous en
dire plus oui on est nul nul blanc non
mais c'est pas que c'est pas gênant
qu'il nul mais là ça va pas être nulle
parce que ça dure la partie longue mais
il n'y a que 21 coups coiffe entier loin
dans le temps mais pas à pas un coup
donc 21 coups joués nul en 21 coups
c'est quand même pas non c'est pas tu
sais pas ça s'est passé pas tout à fait
ça les parties nulles combative elle
font plutôt celle de la quatrième à la
sixième partie le faisait 60 70 coups
s'est pas dit autre chose il y avait
quand même plus de jeu d'abord et là il
ya du jeu il ya un peu de jeu mais là
c'est un jeu minimale quoi c'est vrai
je minimale
les minimales
21 coups de jouer cramique pencher à
beaucoup le public que le public
londonien commence à être franchement
énervé ce qu'ont pu lire puisque
régulièrement ils viennent ils payent
leur place de 100 francs et assiste à
une nulle rapide et pas très combative
non mais là elle est un peu combatif
quand même aujourd'hui mais bon il ya un
peu de jeu mais c'est vraiment léger
quoi j'allais voir notre côté si c'est
des deux meilleurs joueurs du monde
c'est très difficile de jouer
ce qui est clair comme dit kasparov
c'est un match oui et à la fin qu'est ce
qu'on se rappelle on se rappelle pas des
nuls rapide on se rappelle juste du
vainqueur
g league est il inscrit son nom dans
l'histoire
touré buteur dame prend à cette caisse
qui se passe sur d'emprunts 7
alors touré fuite parce qu'il faut re
sûrement revenir en recettes
parce que la torah fuite est trop hâtive
peut-être ces fameuses une j'ai une
proposition sur ce qui s'est passé avec
tomber 8 et aux arbitres castrophe
réfléchi très longtemps et joue tourbe
et vite
il n'a pas vu de sa tour on a mis
d'accord moi le coup vraiment normal
naturel
ouais et notre âme unique surtout huit
n'avaient rien vu
ils savaient pas quoi faire surtout il a
étendu les elle a peut-être déçus retour
de vite il se dit bon alors qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que sur
tours à huit
kasparov a vu quelque chose que moi j'ai
pas vu alors non si si il peut se dire
ça donc il re calcul tout il re calcul
tout et il voit finalement que ce retour
lui qui avait un problème il y avait à
la fin on prenait la tour on a 8 parce
que rouach est damas catéchètes
fourchette et on prend la torah me l'a
peut-être ils voient peut-être un truc
comme ça
oui il peut toujours le faire d'après un
set ça peut donner une indication makram
manque le coup de kasparov non pas pour
un service vérificateur va devenir
comique ça c'est laid c'est impossible
alors que la tombe et 8 c'est vrai qu'
il n'y a pas d'échelle et padilla pas
d'échec qui peut ramasser la tour et
qu'elle soit enfin pas peur de laisser
son plus haut à cette baisse hier qu'en
fait on peut assister éventuellement à
d'un port à sept tours à fuite dano 7 et
tourbe et luttent encore une fois oui
mais ouais ouais ouais tombe huit encore
une fois ça serait la seule case pour la
toux c'est vrai c'est vrai une seule de
ces malades quelque chose qui nous a
échappé
c'est un coup prophylactique il n'a peur
qu'elle soit en fils a eu peur des
échecs sur case blanche
il a peut-être vu quelque chose vous
rajoutez pas vous concret je ne pense
pas qu'il y ait en rien vu du tout sa
part au hasard
est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer cavalier f5
hayatou j'évite toujours ses intérêts
julie gayet 8,1 qui protège g7 qu'adam
tour 5 alors c'est pas possible ça tours
5% qui ont fait tomber un échec
ils ont proposé ne d'un bien roger deux
jeunes g6 et la grée six échecs on peut
mentionner quand même ça se regarde
tours 5
pour empêcher la dame de protéger g7
mais là il ya d'alberich est d'amener un
échec évident et si on revient à la tour
on revient b2 et ça fait nul et sinon au
g2 on ne peut pas empêcher la dame
devenir angers 6 avec un échec et la
nasa ne peut pas vraiment s'échapper il
faut pas les matchs 3 puisqu'il ya
toujours damage six échecs
oui donc là faut revenir en juin ou en
f1 est plutôt en défense et la douane
gênant ce n'était pas possible
mais ça ça n'apportera rien tombé un
échec
damien chèque à noter fait noir peuvent
également aller cherchons à deux si on
fait trop les cons mouais c'est vrai il
ne faut pas jouer au plus fin avec des
richesses par un taureau 5 c'est pas bon
non il ya beaucoup de variantes ou les
noirs et finissent par être mieux
stéphane donc ça tout laisserait à
penser que tram ni devrait certes nul oh
là là là quelle horreur dans les minutes
qui suivent quelle horreur et on aurait
noté aujourd'hui s'est rien passé
c'est une horreur aujourd'hui encore en
vendre
ouais non mais là c'est ça devient ça
deviendrait le move est relâché ça
deviendrait un peu pénible c'est d'une
consécutive là on est devant mais on
s'est fait trop peu a commenté stéphane
mais là c'est le problème c'est que
c'est que ces kasparov qui qui arrive
pas à faire de jeu ses chroniques lui
bon mais non point quand même il a quand
même gagné une partie il a fait trois
très belles parties il en a gagné une il
a fait deux nuls où ils étaient gagnants
et kasparov lui il fait rien à noter
qu'un que s'ils cassent morgan une
partie et bien ça va relancer le cra
munich
enfin six parmi une partie de passes
gros favoris stéphane kick ass part en
favori pour faire match nul heureux
qu'enfin machine oui c'est pas une
grosse victoire
ben oui il est le champion qu'on s'est
ressenti oui mais il aurait fait passer
pas une règle qui est quand même bien
pour le spectacle échecs garry dernier
mise en échec par travnik c'est une
façon de parler bien sûr qu'à vue
chronique quelques radicaux à bord il
reste assis à beaucoup d'attention
contre son propre pays sont venus non
dirigent ou orages et dites moi j'ai
bien joué kasparov c'est curieux ce café
chronique cavaliers gillaque que va-t-il
faire devenir cavalier échec il avait
mentionné cette position où on ne
trouvait pas de moyens de progresser
j'espère faire partie stéphane il est
venu déjouer il est parti je suis venu
j'ai joué et j'ai parti que ce soit pas
forcément analyser tout ça
quelle idée vite on avait dit on avait
parlé de cahiers des vitrines attention
les blancs force de chercher le gain ont
peut-être trouvé la défaite
et oui la force d'essayer de jouer au
plus malin
famille que c'est pas le genre de joueur
et un caïd et 8 ça non je vois pas
facile car on y trouve quelque chose ce
serait fabuleux mais ça serait
extraordinaire
pas trop l'ordinateur dit que quelques
cavaliers d'élite est le seul coup pour
ennuyer garry kasparov
à noter que dame aussi c'est le coup qui
fait de nos grands stefan wey damas six
aussi ça provoque un échec perpétuelle
inédit est immédiat force est à peu près
force et ouais mais ça affaiblit les
noirs ils sont obligés de jouer à 100
c'est ça ouais c'est ça ouais mais c'est
affaiblissant c'est vrai et puis alors
autres autre avantage des mocistes et
femmes c'est bien c'est que la presse 5
on a une découverte du cavalier ouais
mais bon encore une fois pas
spécialement utile mais on a quand même
on l'a on la tient
on y croit on ne lâche pas et là
attention à bon il n'est ce pas un
instant mais ici est-ce qu'on peut pas
continuer la table comme ça stéphane
dion pour remontrer la position ouais ce
qu'on l'a perdu pour l'instant voilà on
montre éventuellement donc après non y'a
plein de l'échec mais ça c'est végé 5
échelle on tourne en rond je suis
efforcé de 9,7 c'est ça dont je pensais
internet simple dames et vii et doit sa
meule instruite et matt commencent à
annoncer menace pas la médaille f5
empêche de juger si ces lois
voilà c'est ça alors ça c'est toute
l'idée c'est que maintenant dans une
position solide et qu'est ce qu'on va
jouer au coup d'après on va jouer tours
notre tête je me dadjé 6 bref on va
pressurisée tout ça un peu à la maison
aussi soit 56 c'est pas mal hein aussi
sa menace tourcoing cavaliers oui tout à
fait waouh
eh oui ici que joue que joue garry
kasparov et baby cuit admettant que
casper joudain prend à 29.2 donc le
prototype du coup l'an ouais
que se passe-t-il sur toi aussi stephen
on peut se poser la question tout aussi
chaud il ya de la tacc quand même une
petite attaque avec un avantage leur
intérieur qui est rare qu'un avantage
alors que les noirs les blancs britz et
les blancs qui sont gagnants ici
stéphane en l'améliorant g8 manger vite
selon moi j'ai deux jeux se passe rien
6il rejet de sa menace de bouger la dame
puisque on est plus dans l'échec après
gross initiative énorme avantage
voilà c'est ça le truc c'est petit ça y
est c'est nécessaire on revient on vous
remonte vous remontre c'est super c'est
joli en tout cas ça de cette très
agréable pour les noirs comme unique
dans cette position va jouer damas six
voilà il est la chronique
c'est vrai on va voir sa menace quoi
eloi et mais gênant que les imaginons
que les noirs jouent par exemple voilà
on va encore le montrer il faut encore
le montrer imaginons que les noirs
jouent on ne s'en lasse pas tu aurais je
suis touré fuite par exemple même temps
au futur encore plus beau toi ton plus
beau tour et fuite
donc là pour prendre le cavalier donc là
les noir et blanc ferait cavalier h6
avait lors stéphanois trophy de san
martino qui que les six à oui elle ça
marche pas ça ne marche elle avait donc
dû réfuter le bon coup et horrifique
titre c'est un coup de défense possible
mais ici qu'est ce qu'il y aurait
surtout la fuite et d'éviter d'aller
cette cg des 8es damas est franc organes
la tour donc alors supposons autre chose
supposons un coup de gomme anodin donne
ces trois mêmes titres ça marche pas non
plus pas si ça marche était haute et
agissent et réagissent échec là le roi
ne peut pas aller en fuite sinon il est
mat par dame f7 il faut aller à un fuite
et la superbe le fameux d'alger vite
fantastique puisque on est obligé de
prendre la dame avec une pièce pas avec
le roi puisque le cavalier empêche sa la
quatrième set
échec et mat et ça serait du kasparov à
l'étouffée alors nous nous revenons sur
la pression c'est celle là voilà
community s'il va jouer dames 6 bien
joué oui tout à fait dès le 6 qui
menacent donc le matin à l'étouffée et
fun menace
ouais le coup seul coup ch 5 maintenant
que kasparov pascal 6 h 6 sa péremption
sur cavani principe oui c'est ça
maintenant qu'elle est g53 fuite
et là on jouerait le ku'damm f5 très
jolies côtes ou simplement idée la cata
cette idée tout rond au cices ramassant
gagner une tour en 1 16 ème tour c'est
au tour ou un set qui pas mal non plus
parce que là il ya plus d'échecs de des
noirs là donc telles attaques continues
et beaucoup d'idées là il est noir et
blanc peuvent ramasser les pions en plus
de lui côté dames éventuellement ouais
enfin augmente tranquillement la lah en
fait les pièces blanches c'est-à-dire la
dame et le cavalier font un peu un
double effet attaque et défense à la
fois ouais le fameux sabre de samouraï
et on sait que tameka blick pour la taxe
est très fort et oui il ya peut-être ça
et oui ça va continuer et oui c'est ça
que ça va continuer c'est pas si facile
on est là on fait une digue nul alors
que alors qu'en fait il ya de la tacc
alors qu'en fait comme d'habitude pas du
tout crâne il est capable de trouver ça
d'ailleurs il avait écrit longtemps
communiquent ils écoutent nos
commentaires et salle ferrière à
saint-cricq rigoler et qu'est ce qui se
passe sur damas il ya un an toro 8
marche pas à cause du mat à munich se
dit ce matin à l'étouffée c'est quand
même l'invention du siècle
ouais ça a été inventé par est idiot
quand il faut inventer
ça a été mis en
en pratique comme indiennes ont
communément reconnues comme étant une
composition intéressante par betty donc
c'est peut-être rappeler qu'ils étaient
réduits et quand est-ce qu'il a sévi non
non ça je ne sais pas trop raidie
faciale joueurs du 20e siècle
c'est un russe avait annoncé je sais pas
non plus c'était pas une question piège
stéphane je fais simplement créé at il
inventé le jeu hyper moderne avec les
banques et aux jets 3 mai 3 il a dit moi
je ne prends pas le centre mecili
attaque tout simplement des conceptions
de richard batty oui un index trop dur
et petits c'est un des mots d'un des
joueurs modernes regarde al'écran nick
wey il est au bout du fusil
il ya un truc à presser la détente
freins knicks auraient sorento potec
pocket est ce que est ce que les noirs
peuvent sacrifier la qualité sur 2 me 6
n'aurait fait ni s'ils peuvent pas c'est
pas possible non et pourquoi annoncer ce
moment il n'y a pas de match ce n'est
pas une qualité commune
non mais oh non
ouais c'est pas clair et sûr que le noir
peuvent nord peuvent éventuellement
sacrifier une qualité aa
et oui dames 6 dames 6 2 chroniques et
ça joue sajou ou sajoo travnik un petit
avantage c'est sûr
g mickaël petit avantage est-ce que ça
suffira
c'est toute la question
ce soir on revient à toutes enjambées
cassadotte désagréable et loi ah oui
ah oui c'est à jouer parce qu'on a pas
mal du coup l'indicé phare des jo
d'hiver quand on n'a pas beaucoup de du
coup à sa disposition
mais en fait stéphane ce qui se passait
toujours du stress la sq est stressant
pour garry kasparov c'est que travail il
ya beaucoup de temps et la sicile se
retrouver très vite la rattraper
alors est-ce que quatre ont pu jouer h6
windows et office manager ça c'est clair
bien sûr et sain ce que l'idée c'est
qu'on prend là avec le pion mais mais
mais après l'orage cette il ya plus des
chaînes arabes unis ça ou la colonne h
même stephen ça c'est grave ça permettra
des dommages 3 buts à 0
peut-être oui on n'a pas spécialement
envie de prendre des mâchoires de la
tête et peut-être c'est possible
effectivement il est pas content il
racontant dans les cordes il y en a
ras-le-bol il en a ras-le-bol kasparov
maman je veux jouer nous enseigne que
sport va dire ben jawad j'en ai
ras-le-bol ce match je rentre chez moi
je vais me préparer pour le prochain
championnat du monde pour les
qualifications pour les qualifs quel que
soit on n'a pas joué de qualification
pour un championnat du monde depuis 1983
est tout à fait où il avait battu
rappeneau année où il avait battu en
finale il a et b to b lipsky l'om et il
avait dû s'y smith l'offre il avait
battu tours est fit nommer stéphane tu
me donnes la qualité tu es ordinaires et
les femmes et ouais ouais effectivement
alors pourquoi ça donne la qualité c'est
ce qu'on nous allons commenter tout de
suite
les deux joueurs sont partis stéphane
mahé castrophe ça qui fait la qualité
s'en va alors survenir pourquoi ça perd
la qualité et bien si d'accueil des mie
d'échelle et d'éviter cheikh est après
rouages suite le coude adam en hausse
est oui ça donne la qualité mais attends
ça donne pas plus que la qualité soit il
faut je te prends des bidasses des
femmes
il en a pas le choix puisque la tour et
attaqué un gâteau revient en
vieillissant j'ai lu ton le montre plus
mais on le montre quand même qu'avec
notre cas l'élève cet échec et mat à
l'étouffée donc il faut prendre le
cavalier pas le choix est vite
évidemment autre possibilité ici après
2007 c'est de jouer trop vite mais là on
ne montre plus non plus si on le montre
cela on le montre iliad 1.81 prend 1,8
et après qui abriteront et ne reprendre
le tour avec échec et mat échec et mat
donc ici gary après davos est
la position celle ci on est allé
d'éviter chaque mois je suis d'abord
répète il faut jouer seul coup tout j'ai
vite ton qu'on devine ses forces et on
va voir dans une belle partie basse cour
comment ça se fait qu'il ait joué ça
aussi vite donne rendez vite que j'avais
j'ai vu forcé est là mais je crois qu'il
est complètement cuit kasparov ici
qu'est ce qui se passe est annoncée par
l'ordinateur il est cuit séparer ainsi
s'il échoue il est franic jouer dans des
salles des cinq défend tous les pions et
clinton c'est tellement plus fort mutv
des stéphanois mais défend tous les
pions mais oui mais non c'est fini ça il
ya égalité mais c'est complètement king
pourquoi les joies comme cela ça s'en
venait
cad c'est pas vrai c'est une cagade
stéphane c'est ça serait une cagade 2k
sports
j'y crois pas alors alors oui c'est fini
la saison après toi suite ils atteignent
des mythes et dams est c'est fini
oh non non non c'est pas possible que ce
soit en forêt pas d'un des cinq maisons
mesdames dessins qu'il y aura des médias
qui n'y a qu'à voir si ces lois
concernant le dessin qui n'ont comme en
mai donnent des trois c'est la tourette
beaucoup de tours 5e nina non il y
aurait pas d m6 parce qu'ils aiment à
8.7 gagnants en bout terminée traque
boom
il semblerait que rami va jouer une
finale avec une qualité une qualité plus
notre ami ne comprend pas là il est ko
devant un échiquier chronique c'est pas
possible
là il faudrait voir à ne m a dit qu il
laisse rien passer de la compétence il a
l'air content comme nick a l'air content
mais c'est pas possible ça aurait fait
une gaffe une gaffe une guerre terrible
n'a pas vu qu'elle est d'éviter des
recettes non mais c'est pas possible
si si si si c'est la réalité stéphane
qui dépasse la fiction c'est qui ce
sport qui se plante
sa non non quoi assis et on va montrer
comme il y avait autre chose qu'on n'a
pas montré encore une autre chose avec
quoi et des vitesses avec des huit
échecs ont ensuite pour ces dames où
cette dame si on peut dire pourquoi pas
rouler vite et bien moi j'ai vite ça a
l'air pas mal
et oui mais là cavalier aussi ce mail
après il y a il ya l'agglo drame qui
avait aussi scaglia six attaques la tour
et le pion g7 restions j'étais sur tours
fc est surtout à vii ses fans que se
passe-t-il et bien d'amd 8
c'est horrible d'amd vite cet affront
suivi du mat celui du matrix et matt
point interposés lecavalier
puis la tour mais la dame prend toutes
les pièces notera aussi que ce sport au
fait rater ça c'est il ya trois pieds
sur l'échiquier
c'est déjà trop c'est déjà trop grave il
va le faire
ça se passe assez grand il va donc mener
non mais comme il va mener 2 à 0
test europe n'aura q26 parti pour se
refaire et là il faudra donc battre
chronique 4 2 ne serait pas possible ça
sert de cette partie qui allie aller
vers la nuls soit gagné par kramnik sur
une gaffe de kasparov quand même palace
le faire garry kasparov une brioche une
cave de kasparov à ce moment là va nous
manger tout cru on aura les oreilles
bouchées on le croit pas anormal en
class40 a jugé cette position c'est pas
possible
mais non mais ses fans en mai c'est très
clair non mais pour 10 joué 17 cournoyer
rennais chine en russie on leur apprend
aux enfants que cette finale est
perdante
il espère en ce sens rappelle avec sa
mémoire est-ce que kramnik va rater
cavaliers des huit zones ans ou
peut-être qu'il va trouver plus fort non
plus d'être non mais c'est finalement
peut-être pas gagnante et loire si si si
si sessegnon 6 6 est gagnant didier loi
est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer cavalier de
17 pour défendre la tour ans
y aurait d'un proximedia dame prend
cavalli mais mais mais mais après la
tour son réveil pour taper des pieds en
f3 non non non mais je pense
effectivement qu'on peut retenir un oeil
à la finale puisque j'avais pas
désarçonné tiquement qu'elle gagne en
talents français tu sais pas sur quelles
limites dgeq rouages celui dont la suite
dames cette hausse est bon il faut
prendre
non là oui il faut prendre il faut
prendre pendant des vite pour prendre 18
d'un prend comme point kg bikaï g8 et la
dame des cinq tranquille enfin à ce tour
8es loi lequel il peut pas bouger il
faut voix semblant joue à coup comme si
ce nom
ainsi ce père éloi faut jouer câble est
6 h 6 faire à cause de tours 8
même si c'est dur de perdre à cause de
tour vis annoncé par les ars et perd
tout de suite alors annoncé un recours à
wayne on ça marche paris on va nous
montrer quand même emploi justice au
taureau mythe c'est la cagade on est
trop vite ce serait la cagade puisque il
y aurait des richesses d'un bhl sorti
roger deux mois j'ai donné la dame g6
ramasse la tour d'alger si ce boom avec
le roi et les rebonds à masquer la tour
du valat hymne possible ça marche pas
donc là il faut à 20 h 6 h ici il faut
trouver autre chose on peut jouer roger
donon peut jouer des 9,7 pour contre les
gaz g6 bref grosse attaque pour le non
la mef 7 c'est pas malin et si stéphane
de 9 km 7 et pas mal puisque ça
contrôler la case justice et sa menace
tours 8
ça m'agace horwitz et menace d'un procès
de signal ces menaces dame prend à cette
aussi et bien entendu évidemment mais
dans ce cas là pourquoi on joue pas
d'arrêt c'est de tout de suite parce
qu'on pouvait pas la dame étant des
mutins et services et sur tf6 alors là
évidemment il ya d'un procès qui a l'air
pas mal mais bon on joue donc gros 1,6
et le cavani étant une pièce à courte
portée
il ne pourra pas attendre défendre ses
pions et ça sera un gain l'asie ni assez
gagné il l'avion
non c'est pas plus sinon il est
complètement dominé par ed
ils auront achevé mais il n'y a pas le
choix il a peut-être vu nos médailles
dont il connaît cette finale parker
presse-sports c'est pas possible je suis
cramique ne comprends pas non mais
qu'est ce temps fort et fait une gaffe
une gaffe historique d'internet le
hashtag perdre et perdre et c'est
peut-être cash 5 perdre et c'est vrai
que l'ordinateur ne trouvait pas de
gains il évite tout de suite mais
s'affaiblit terriblement la position
dure en noir c'est possible alors qu'il
vient aussi d'un des six pour chronique
qui conduit à la même position d'un de
sept éric ramic joue la variante bailar
kasparov n'a pas le choix le sol du
salève syndicat unia d'enfer sur castro
non mais attention aux castors enfin
toujours dans mes cavaliers il a tord
vient d'être détrônée tête qu'est ce qui
n'a pas vu il l'a pas vu il l'a pas vu
non ah c'est possible mais non c'est
possible comment ça il aurait pas vus il
me l'aurait peuvent peut-être surtout il
a une innovation sur une chronique à
temps et rien comme il attend il a
attendu l'abandon 1
mais non c'est pas possible tu entends
non mais il faut absolument montrent les
images sur kasparov la norme ias tout
reprendre cavaliers loi c'est pas tes
pas terminée iad faut rappeler quand
même c'est fini on va on va le lire sur
le visage de kasparov
attention aujourd'hui cac scor perd
peut-être son titre mondial
cram nick va peut-être marqué le
deuxième point aujourd'hui qui lui
donnerait deux points avance dans le
match où la tête de gasparo fils il a
fait une gaffe c'est incroyable ils vont
complètement incroyable c'est
complètement stupéfiant ce qui arriva
kasparov et complètement incroyable oui
et oui ça y est
les range sa montre il va abandonner il
va entrer chez eelv a abandonné ouais
c'est fini après davos a abandonné
classe par an terminé c'est pas possible
kasparov abandonner cette position ouais
non non on ne peut pas il va pas
abandonner ce fonds jouer ça va se jouer
dans bien jouer loi il faut la jouer
cette finale jusqu'au bout 1 mais
stéphane les pressions cas sport zhu
même quand il est perdant il ya encore
des chances
là c'est une position perdante sans
aucune chance non non aucune chance
aliments bien autant ouais mais c'est ça
c'est fini c'est terminé c'est terminé
c'est terminé il est ko kasparov non
c'est pas possible il est ko caspar au
sort et chaos non mais on a du mal à le
croire et loire ça fait quand même 15
ans si ça fait 15 ans qu'on n'a jamais
vus kaskarot l'a oublié quelque chose
ils oublient un truc kasparov là il est
donc il a il peut pas jouer cette finale
avec une qualité de moins messi va la
jouer il faut qu'il s'accroche
il faut qu'il s'accroche kasparov
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a abandonné il
a vendu il abandonne casse garry
kasparov abandonne il a paru ce matin
croyable à abandonner leurs amis mènent
2 0
c'est c'est incroyable c'est fabuleux
il s'en va kasparov les idées et bien ça
y est je suis rappelé à la conférence de
presse stéphane à un finish sivola là
c'est elle croyait ce qui est en train
de se passer
un finish incroyable alors qu'on pensait
qu'il pouvait peut-être encore joué
cette finale et loi kasparov abandonne
on vient de vivre
probablement un moment historique
kramnik viennent de gagner contre
kasparov et mène maintenant 2 à 0 le
match est quasiment plié il reste à
peine cinq parties à kasparov pour
monter deux points ce serait du jamais
vu et on voit pas comment il pourrait
gêner chronique qui pour l'instant
dominant plus le match c'est incroyable
ce qui est arrivé aujourd'hui et bien
tout simplement kasparov abandonne dans
cette position incroyable incroyable
kasparov a fait une gaffe terrible
terrible gaffe sur la fin le couteau est
en fuite
il n'a pas vu la petite combinaison de
chroniques
c'est incroyable
kasparov chaos kasparov ko debout alors
que eric giler l'abitre mais micro pour
les joueurs pour la conférence de presse
et il reste plus
c'est incroyable il reste plus que mon
pardon si parti il reste six parties il
reste plus que six parties à kasparov
pour remonter deux points c'est beaucoup
de points ainsi parti il aura que trois
fois les blancs il faut gagner deux fois
sur trois et ça on va pas comment il va
faire kasparov
olala cette partie incroyable krainik
qui a mené toute la partie initiative et
bourde de kasparov comme dans la
deuxième partie cramique
sera-t-il le 14e champion du monde
d'échecs depuis la ligne est interrompue
commencer par steinitz à la fin du 19e